all right chris hey how you doing man
you're good we're live huh you have to
follow douglas murray that's not easy
yeah that's right yeah he's always the
best dressed you and him are both very
well dressed you're doing all right i'm
doing all right i'm trying uh so look
everyone knows my feelings on people
that just talk for a living versus
people that actually do things you're on
the short list of people that do things
you've really started getting some wins
against critical race theory it's pretty
freaking impressive man that's right
yeah we've gotten wins in the policy
sphere we've gotten bills and board of
education uh directives in 10 states
governing 75 million people they're
telling us to talk a little louder if
possible yeah talk louder yeah and um
and i think two
one of the things that's really been fun
is that this was a
not in the consciousness of the american
public a year ago and now you heard even
today at the conference uh josh hawley
talking about it tez cruz talking about
it marco rubio talking about it the
people who are in uh positions of
of high politics have have absorbed the
the information the the praxis the
the the language that we've uncovered
and created in the last year
and it's turning into a political issue
because people care about it you know
when you actually talk about
parents families real people um this
engages them at that emotional level and
when you connect with that the sky's the
limit in a weird way was it almost a
blessing in disguise that they started
coming after kids now the way that they
did that
of course we don't want that to be but
you see what's going on in virginia
right now and it's like maybe it's going
to be critical race theory and mcauliffe
who keeps saying that parents don't have
a right to be involved in their
children's education it's so over the
top bananas that a guy like you you must
be like thank you terry mccollum i
appreciate it yeah and the the numbers
are are pretty stunning you have
two months ago
glenn younkin pivoted his campaign he
made critical race theory his closing
argument
and then all of a sudden once he started
talking and connecting with people um
you see that the issue among voters goes
to number one
and then you see a 42 point shift in
those voters towards yonkin because he's
connecting with something that matters
and then aided by mcauliffe's gaffe
where he's saying parents should not be
involved parents should be out of the
classroom crazy
and then you see wow this is a gaffe
that reveals his true thing he's going
to walk it back
he doubled down
just yesterday on meet the press or one
of the morning shows he said oh yeah i
was completely right and everybody
clapped
everybody clapped in his mind but no
voters in virginia are clapping for that
because
it's one thing when you say well you've
talked to so many people these are the
problems in the universities this is the
corruption in academia this is what's
going wrong in the bureaucracy
the average american say yeah that's
wrong that's stupid that's corrupt uh it
doesn't affect me
but when you put that between parent and
child
you're activating a different set of
reactions and a different set of
emotions
and you're now getting that ferocious
pushback where people who are even
saying i'm on the left i'm a democrat i
voted for biden
but i don't want this what do we need to
do to get rid of this
where did i get it yeah yeah i mean
you're going to attack kids it's one
thing when people let themselves be
attacked but you start attacking the
kids something does change
what do you think are the next places we
could get some wins let's assume that
this goes well tomorrow i mean obviously
fingers crossed it seems like it sends a
message but where are the other places
that you're working on some stuff right
now i mean what the great thing about
this is it's decentralized it's a
grassroots movement with some of us in a
leadership position uh but not in a
top-down position we're providing
information we're providing vocabulary
we're providing some inspiration
but you have i think in the now at more
than a thousand school districts parents
that are rallying together to fighting
against us at the local level and we can
replicate this on the different axes of
this cultural battle so we're doing
critical race theory we can see an
analogous movement if we get some better
leadership on critical gender theory
we can see an analogous movement on all
these different uh axes or verticals of
these cultural battles that are starting
to seep into mainstream culture that are
starting to affect people directly
and and i talk to people all the time in
my community you know
normal small town
that they're really for the first time
starting to
ask questions
and if we can provide a trail of answers
to those questions
we can now
mobilize people in a way where i
sometimes feel like even this group this
is a fairly large group but it's a very
small group compared to the billions
upon billions of dollars that are pumped
into these ideologies
in the opposition
but we have something that i think is
powerful for people and i think with
critical race here we've demonstrated
with
like me james lindsay you a couple guys
and gals yeah
we can actually uh force them on the
defensive and i think that's to me the
the greatest hope is that a small group
of people with a fierce commitment to
the truth with a sophisticated strategy
to subvert this stuff can move the
needle that's why they hate you so much
because you're going on the offensive
yeah
roofo's you can't
he's attacking us we're the ones that
are supposed to be attacking they're
used to um a pathetic defensive strategy
oh well we're going to protest this we
don't like this but eventually they know
they're going to fold um and and
what are we defending at this point um
uh
the the territory is so limited i think
we have no choice but to actually go on
offense
and it's a it's a rich environment this
stuff is ridiculous yeah it should be
mocked it should be it should be exposed
it should be um
the people who are
are using your money my money taxpayer
money to promote it should be humiliated
this is why um
trump being out of the spotlight is i
think going to
uh um
provide a new space for some of this
discussion because they can't just say
well trump bad trump trump's gone
trump's on the
sidelines for now for now but let's
let's really kind of dig into the issues
let's dig into the substance of it um
that's not a useful kind of
kind of brain sucking device
people are thinking and with bill maher
i mean we have to just point out
logically
you have the premise
like the conclusion is built into your
your premise like
just you don't and you don't have to be
a
ted cruz supporting republican but just
cross off the line to say we don't want
this right just cross that line he's
close and ironically bill maher would be
welcomed at a conference like this a lot
of people would say hey
they love him yeah all right that is the
message to bill maher and the remaining
liberals be like this guy who went all
the way and he's you're actually
changing the world man all right great
stuff thanks if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell